[Music]
good morning babe
welcome to a day in your life what we
like to do in the morning is coffee we
love coffee first I start this notice
that this Kettle it's Advanced at least
for us it has different temperatures
this is the only Kettle that I get this
Kettle is a dream they're not sponsoring
me I'm not sponsored I don't even know
who makes this Kettle then while that's
boiling I generally take my supplements
at least recently to take NAC so Knack I
take berberine right now I'm trying out
saffron every single day I'll take
vitamin D while the coffee is cooling
down I go on this vibration machine and
I do some mental exercises I'm a fairly
private person so I'm not going to say
exactly what I'm doing but it's for my
cognition verbal Acuity facts mental
notes something like a cognitive
exercise I do over here and I attempt to
look at the sun because Andrew huberman
said this is extremely important in the
morning to get a certain amount of
sunlight in your eyes immediately I
suffer from Fairly crippling insomnia
for instance last night I only slept for
just a couple hours and it's been
consistently like that because we're
moving into this office which you'll see
at some point oh in case you're
wondering what this is about this is
because if you're just listening to this
then you'll think oh there's a vibration
machine yeah take your mind out of
you're not that lucky there's not that
kind of day in life this just Shakes You
works out your core because you have to
stabilize yourself at the gym some
people want to know what is it that I
listen to do I listen to podcasts do I
listen to music I try to not listen to
podcasts I never listen to music anyway
so that's not an option so is it that
you don't like music
I don't enjoy music no it can be
annoying because I love music yeah so
that's like quiet but we manage it I
take out one of these cups I love these
cups I have a set of them they're so
huge my gripe or my pet peeve is when
you have cups in the Piney and I have to
keep refilling again this is a common
theme I don't like to waste time so I
love these cups however I have this rule
that I've imposed on myself that I want
more of these cups but I can't get them
for myself
I have to get them from someone who
genuinely has this relationship so my
father gave me this so son my sister
gave me this says brother and my brother
gave me this says brother as my wife
gave me this soul mates then I use this
Nest Cafe with some of this in here and
then how do you make your coffee I take
the coffee black but it's a bit of a
flavor I don't eat dinner until about 6
p.m or so but every day in the morning
time I take this or try to this is
omega-3 can I go
my wife winces
she can't stand that
no she doesn't like it nor does she like
to see that oil just pouring oil in her
mouth personally I like the counter
extremely clean I don't even like doing
this with the greens I like blowing them
because I don't want it to smear notice
this I love the fact that this is
touchless I'm not an expensive person I
me and my wife we don't have expensive
tastes this brings me joy and brings my
wife Joy even here notice I'm wearing
socks inside I don't understand how some
people they wear shoes in the house even
when they come in they put their shoe on
this side they don't stay on the mat the
mat is there for a reason where exactly
did they step now I have to take alcohol
and disinfect that area because the
shoes are shoes are nasty man this is a
place that my wife houses these
reprehensive
aromatherage Aroma yeah I don't like
this at all this is the greatest source
of tension in our marriage this there's
many fights about this user so I love
this diffuser yeah so this smells I love
the scents it just makes me happy it's
the most unnecessary part of our home I
have a high sensitivity to discuss and
it smells like mildew although it is not
because I've seen it with alcohol all
the time that it actually does but yeah
so she claims so she claims smells
lovely this is the toe setup that's the
monitor it's off right now and this is
the mic this is the webcam I use now on
this which is called a Plexi cam I use
this pen and this pen exclusively for
years I love the way that it writes
virtually every aspect of the house is
on the Google Assistant hey Google it's
podcast time
that turns on that turns on that's
facing away because it's too powerful
and I just need it reflected this is at
the lowest setting that's how bright
that is then this light turns blue the
background will usually set up a red
light as well while I'm drinking the
coffee I'm at my desk and I'm doing work
that happens for about 10 minutes 20
minutes sometimes an hour sometimes two
hours this is by the way the washroom
which is why it's always closed and this
is the single washroom so my poor wife
when I'm doing a four hour Behemoth
podcast with or live stream she will
have to hold it in or there are
alternative means I won't talk about
that I'm done showering I come out and
my wife has my clothes laid for me so I
don't have to think if hey if I'm
dressed well that's my wife if I'm not
dressed well though you can also blame
my wife
foreign
this is a meeting just about goals
essentially going over that document
that I had sent most importantly how are
you doing right now I'm fine I'm
flustered I will say later if uh we'll
stay till seven let's just do a debrief
of how yesterday and today has went so
far specifically this morning we have
already gotten messages back to Anthony
which I think is really good and you're
giving him a fire hose of input that
he's going to be able to deal with he
must get to the point where there is no
rush
for a podcast to be published what I
mean by that is this right now is a rush
as far as the introductions go it could
be you dress nicely saying hey this is
the guest that's coming on in a nice
well-lit room
pre-recorded for the next 20 episodes
and that way we don't have to waste time
doing that and it could be spent on the
crucial editing at the time when it
needs to happen down to a day yeah the
second is going to be the quality
improvement of the overlays so if you're
talking about something highly technical
that we have some content or some media
that directly corresponds to that
alternatively what could be done is we
spend a week Gathering as much footage
related to the research of that
particular individual so that you have
an intro that basically is like a reel
if we don't have the resource to send
somebody there we simply ask them can we
use this footage blah blah we've taken
10 different things from the internet
and we say could this be used in the
introductory that's fine that ladder is
fine now the former I would say no
unless we use that footage for something
else because that's way too expensive
for an introduction shot are they
basically equal in difficulty
yes yeah so I think that it could be
both we could even have it in the
introduction because it's a 30 second
introduction or a minute introduction
and you're flipping through all these
Graphics very quickly and then later in
that episode you'll see that graphic
yeah yeah yeah oh okay both as in yes it
can go in the introduction and it can be
interjected yes let's test that with the
next video like ASAP Let's test that oh
my God Kurt if we have a guest that
could speak for 10 minutes on a 10
second question there could be a whole
series dedicated just to them I spend a
whole two days with them and it's just a
series on all the answers they have
that's that's a full playlist no that's
already we're already tripling our
volume
okay now how okay for this let's talk
about this okay what was your what were
you gonna say because you're like oh we
may be in sync in the in the idea for
this uh immediately we can amplify the
quality of their side by me going to
them if they're in North America just
give me a bus don't even fly me there
let's do it super cheap I get there with
uh with um with some gear yeah gear
yeah
okay how can we make those sections
different because we should make it
visually distinctive
right now we gotta go get a desktop
computer because that computer is taking
way too long to download and it should
have been downloaded already and
something else that's supposed to arrive
hasn't arrived and this is the first day
and there's so much that needs to be
done ASAP because we have this day in
the life so we have to plan this
recording in addition to editing a
podcast which needs to go out in 48
hours because there are sponsors
depending on them that's something that
people don't think about is that we
can't release podcasts whenever you want
you have to think about what other
obligations do you have and what are
people depending on thank you
and you all will just wait in the car
I'll park right out front
that have been good to catch on camera
had a parking ticket at least five years
parking ticket is the sign that someone
does not have a handle on their life
this is a sign of chaos yeah it happened
at your own building yeah it happened in
my own building oh record this and did
one of us not have a seat belt on or
were we
yeah did you have your seatbelt on vest
no backside we don't need right oh no
you need everywhere
put on your seatbelt and you're gonna
make sure this doesn't fall okay
that's fine just we're gonna deal with
that noise
38 minutes 40 minutes
that's pretty that's not bad
thank you
[Music]
you know operators versus okay so what
constitutes a well-formed session right
you're right you should remove because
I'm cutting him off there must be some
reason I see here there's always cuts
Jazz must have done that for some reason
who can modify who and so on so what
constitutes a well-formed census yeah
exactly okay so grammar is the specific
it's not ideal but it's better than him
trailing off I had a question here you
say I'm sorry and I was going to remove
it but it seems like it's kind of a
bridge you need to cut it entirely or
keep it as a natural sorry okay and I'm
just gonna continue notice this
it's so low with a clean interface and
accessories.com I still notice it still
needs a bit more gain just from the
levels and I like how you nodded yeah
no you just don't trust anything now
after seeing this
now we're live streaming the chat GPT
interview and so we're responding to
some of the comments 300 people that's
great some people say interesting or
great question then they toggle the
timestamps and then I'm looking okay
there that was a good question now I
make note uh that's great it's great to
know if someone was to say something
negative about a question then I can
know that too and say okay well why did
someone not like that is this something
that we would like to change in the
future we used to heart every comment
every comment that wasn't insulting to
the guest weird hearts even if it's
insulting to me that's fine there's no
deleting of any comments Hearts doesn't
indicate that I like the comment it
mainly indicates that I read the
comments mainly a system for myself to
know which ones do I need to respond to
which ones do I need to read more well
you are looking to respond to comments
what are you looking for
if they're asking a question especially
if they're asking a question that
involves my name and they also took the
time to reach out so I want to respond
to them this is hilarious you read that
I bet they spent half the training I'll
make sure that it doesn't go full races
experiential and experience okay
thrusting is when someone tries to
indicate that their toe is correct and
they force the conversation in that
direction so let's say a guest comes on
and then they're like yeah but you
should listen to Mito I have the tote
and then when someone's like yeah but
so-and-so then they get a bit offensive
or sorry defensive they become a bit
offensive too I find that people who are
on to something or truly have had some
form of Enlightenment they're much more
humble if you ask them do you have the
toe The Theory of Everything they tend
to say I don't know that's the idea of
like prescribing your own belief onto
other people yeah yes yes yeah like at a
metaphysical level like that's a
political level usually this is like a
metaphysical version of that I see
someone gave four dollars
super kind and she left the person came
that often happens someone will just
donate and then they'll leave
yeah yeah like talk about generosity
they're not even sticking around for the
thank you or for the plot it's no one's
asked about what the heck is this in the
video
[Laughter]
I guess that's what you're sad about are
you
find it funny
a pink catboy could I don't remember
what that was I think that was Halloween
at a club
yeah does that make it easier harder for
you to understand it makes it not boring
for me I cannot listen to Media of any
sort on regular speed it's excruciating
this video doesn't seem like it but this
video took three and a half days of full
editing most podcasts take about a day
or so this one took three because we had
to get the transcript and for some
reason it didn't save the transcript
which means we have to use an AI to
capture this copy and paste it somewhere
else there'd be mistakes we had to edit
that then get this and screen record
this and crop that and also truncate any
times that there were errors there were
several errors when you speak to chat
GPT you'll constantly get timeout errors
or it'll log you out and we tried to
remove all of that and then also most of
the time it would repeat its answers
just keep saying that's a complex a
multi-faceted issue overall intelligence
is a complex and multifaceted concept
that is difficult decision of whether or
not to integrate machine complex and
multiple one the question has happened
we're gonna have to remove that and then
think well if we remove that then it now
doesn't flow and so we had to have so
many rounds of back and forth editing of
this and this seems like it's not much
work but this was three full days and
three and a half full days of editing I
never worry that by editing around you
feel like you're taking away the meaning
yes that's what we have to make sure
that we don't do for any of the actual
human podcast guests when we edit it's
primarily for flow we never remove
content we will make it more engaging
that's a better way of saying it most of
the time it's my own inarticulacies or a
bathroom break there's constantly fires
to put out here like constantly fires
fires fires I'm just wondering when will
there be a day here without something
extremely horrible happening like when
will we just have a date where I can
just study for 10 12 13 hours straight
just come here just be like hey I'm
gonna be in that room until they kick us
out I'm just gonna study when will that
happen much of the time here until it's
me flustered and flummoxed and frazzled
coming to Sam saying look this was
supposed to go out now and that's not
and there's this issue and there's this
issue and I can't handle this why is
this happening there shouldn't be a half
it sounds like okay what what is on your
like Sam can tell you his own yeah it's
absolute chaos in here but it's a it's a
good chaos because we've asked for this
we basically put our foot down to the
floor so that we can be Innovative and
so that we can be different that point
on Innovation is super important because
often we'll have the idea like oh I like
the video that this person created but
then that's not good enough we don't
want to copy someone else we want people
to look to us and say oh I love that
idea I want to copy that the whole point
of this is that we're just ramping up
this flywheel to put out more quality
content so that we can all do what we
love so that it could eventually just
move of its own accord and we have
systems strategies and routines in place
right now we're building them so it's
hugely messy and I'm just hoping I'm
just praying that it'll get to the point
where I can just study for like 14 hours
if I want I can study for 16 hours
straight oh my gosh
that's your dream that's the Holy Grail
yes that's the Holy Grail
[Music]
days way more turmoil than I thought
however the initial steps that needs to
be taken so that we can crank out more
toe content so I can just focus on what
I want to focus on which is studying for
podcasts
there's something called hitch and
moduli space which is related to the
Higgs bundle which I want to learn more
about in preparation for an interview
that I have on Friday as well as
something called geometric language
that's related to a unified theory of
math and I'm curious if that's related
to unified theory and physics that's
already an extremely intense undertaking
to do in weeks or even months and trying
to compress the fifth notes within a few
hours because I also have to add atop
that some work in something called an
amplitahedron and all of that again has
to be done by Friday which is less than
48 hours away because I'm staying late I
want to see can I get to any of this in
the next couple hours how can I
understand all of that material at what
level of understanding do I need what do
I want to accomplish are we going to do
another one of these videos do people
like it
I'm self-conscious right now so I'm
thinking about that here's an example of
being self-conscious should I be looking
at the camera should I be looking at you
am I moving my hands too much is my
posture correct so there's so much
that's on my mind your task would just
be a camera operator again once more but
then after that we want you to do remote
tests mainly working on Photoshop so
thumbnails for the toe Channel some
editing and ask for what else we're not
sure yet yeah on Monday Tuesday
thank you
hey uh why are some of the symbols of
your uh or some of the letters these
refer to different projects or ideas or
concepts I'm fairly secretive person so
I'm reticent most of the time much of
this is enigmatic for instance this that
says Albert that doesn't refer to what
you may think like Alberta or someone
named Albert if you're referring to this
with my right hand I write forward and
then with my left hand I write backward
there are various reasons and again some
of it's related to code some it's just a
quirk of mine
because I'm a strange person
yeah I haven't had any Tim Hortons this
morning
uh so thinking about came back the first
day it's very hectic how was it for you
oh the first day was crazy yeah because
we had to get a lot of things set up and
figure out also how we're going to work
together best in the office because so
far we've been remote we've been a
distributed team and we need to figure
out how are we going to create
amazing content
and have more of it going out without
the limitations that we had when we were
apart from each other essentially in the
morning we first have a morning meeting
so this is like our brief for the day
we'll also have a debrief at the end of
the day but everything in between that
is basically subject to to any change
that could possibly happen most of the
day is figuring out how can I pull a lot
of the energy from Kurt that I can take
on so that he has the availability to
study and prepare for the guests that
are coming up there's always an issue
right some technical issue or there
could be some overlap in the schedule
that needs to be managed so basically I
handle everything that he doesn't want
to deal with and make his life more
convenient
foreign
we have a meeting with someone
over Zoom so we're simply waiting if
that will make it better
hey Google call 289 let me make sure the
time is correct sure 4 P.M it's a zoom
link yeah
is that okay
the subject line okay gotcha yeah yeah
yeah all right bye-bye
okay sorry about that once again that
was entirely on me my dad yeah don't
worry about it however
um I'm not entirely sure about the job
duties that's what I need to be more
clarified for instance right now
you'll see there are some people right
here some good people and they're
filming this what they've done is filmed
us today because you've seen these
videos that are called Day in the Life
videos of YouTubers right so we're doing
a day in the life but an honest Day in
the Life meaning that we're not making
our day perfect we have plenty of
footage here we would be giving you all
of this footage we would sync it up so
that it's much easier for you we'd get
you to look at a few day in the lives
and get you to direct today in the life
like come up with one on your own that's
a huge project like that's its own mini
documentary film all right so then
you'll be the Assembly of the footage
compilation of a plot line uh yes we
just have footage right now we have so
much footage and we just need it
compiled oh get the footage and then I
would try to find some inspiration
online and create a pitch deck so I
could send it off to Sam and then Sam
from there you can sort of approve what
the storyline of for example the day in
life is going to be like and if there it
would be a refining of that storyline
into a 10 minute video yeah it could be
10 some people go up to 35 minutes we're
not sure we've recorded quite a slew of
footage so good luck to you man I can
make a suggestion yes
this seems less like a day in the life
and more so like um what it's what it
takes to run a podcast you know what
what it takes to to make something
happen yeah not necessarily dipping a
Tillman but more so jumping into the
deep end and seeing what happens yeah
okay right all right that's exciting
it's exciting okay I'm happy with that
I'd like that right now and you've done
this in the first time that we spoke
that you've suggested your own thoughts
and you're not afraid to tell us what
you think you're not hesitant so that's
great I and Sam wants you to not just
think of this as a gig but to think of
it as something that you can help shape
by all means yeah I'm really happy to
speak my mind I I love the sound of my
own voice so I'll talk for hours on end
until you tell me to shut up eventually
what are you working on the guests for
the next few weeks maybe even a couple
months I just like a guests firstly I
try to make sure that it's not someone
in the public sphere already so not
someone who has been interviewed on
several podcasts like Michael malice or
Andrew huberman or Jordan Peterson
although Jordan Peterson interviewed me
but that's different we mirrored that
it's not solely about the views
interviewing those individuals would
increase your subscriber count and your
views but we have a longer term goal the
goal of toes of explicating one of the
aspects that people seem to adore is
that it's built toward a singular
purpose and that is a theory of
everything what guest comes up I'm
thinking about what Theory of Everything
do I need to understand what are the
prerequisites for that so for instance
Brian Greene is an expert in Mira
Symmetry and flop transitions flop
transitions is related to super gravity
in 11 and five Dimensions so who else is
an expert on that so I can study that in
order to study for Brian Green and I sit
them down like it's office hours rather
than it's like let me just have a chummy
back and forth I don't care about that I
know that's rude but there's something
authentic about treating it like a
professor's office hours where I just
have question marks in my own mind and
I'm trying to fill them so I go bullet
point can you explain this yes or no I
still don't understand this this and
this ah okay now let's move on to the
next one what about this this and this
ah but how does that relate to this and
this it's not aha tell me about your
childhood or what's your favorite poem
or what are your favorite books I
noticed that some podcasts they start
off as let's say the computer science
podcast and then it slowly morphs into
the John Smith podcast hole will be the
opposite of that the polar opposite of
that it will never be renamed to Kurt J
Mongol what do you want to accomplish
with each interview like I mentioned
there are certain necessary
preconditions for other interviews so
I'm trying to knock those out as if it's
University and have prerequisites for
courses if I understand the theory more
and I've explained it to myself but also
to the audience more then that's a great
interview we also try to think about how
can we intermittently place in
avant-garde content so that is to say
not three podcasts in a row with the
same topic for instance chat GPT is
coming up and that's a great one we can
place that anywhere because it's a
special video however then we have to
think about timing because chat gbt is
becoming old news further they may
release chat GPT too so there's time
pressure each hour we feel behind the
scenes each tow podcast is meant to be
like a gem
almost every frame is curated when we
cut there's a certain reason that we cut
the whole podcast should have a flow to
it and what I'm also trying to do is
have a flow with the guest lineup so for
the tote Channel as well not just within
a podcast but aesthetically I want it to
be Bonnie for the whole Channel if
someone else was running tall they would
think that's not pertinent in the least
you're just wasting time who cares about
that people get scented on the algorithm
and they may see two years from now I
care about that there's something that
is an Artistry that impels me that I
hope people pick up on I spend 100 hours
a week just to ensure that that care
shines through at each level I'll leave
here at 2AM if I have to I notice other
podcasts interview a variety of guests
such as MMA fighters people promoting
their books wow why don't you do that
while we're heavily focused on just
tolls it's just about theories of
everything if there is an errant guest
like on video games
then
there is a larger plan to integrate them
into the wider umbrella of tolls
Seinfeld is one of my favorite shows and
then Breaking Bad for drama Breaking Bad
one of the reasons it was so great was
that it had an end in mind the Creator
said you know this is going to be a
story of naive and innocent High School
teacher becomes Scarface and that was
the end that they were building toward
that so for toe for theories of
everything we're building towards
something there's an end in mind it's to
help formulate my own Velton as well
once that's done I imagine that toll
will be near complete or would transform
into something else maybe I'm no longer
a part of it
[Applause]
someone sent me a knife like a fan of
toad he's like I see that you have
patreon and that people can donate but I
can't afford it however I Forge knives
can I make you a knife that's awesome so
I told them that I'm totally happy and
like a flatter and he doesn't have to
provide anything but he's like I would
love to somehow toe went into this knife
because he listens to them when he makes
other people's knives off this is so
cool
that is gorgeous great what a gift thank
you thank you thank you so much I will
take this home apparently and I can't
dishwash this he told me that in the
email I will clean this I will disinfect
this as a you know me is this a UFO
yep
that's Sam's that's not mine yeah
[Music]
we're trying to wrap we're gonna be
dropping some people home and I need to
see my wife at some point some of these
people who do day in the lives or just
in this space in general use as a badge
of honor how much they work I don't I
don't think so I don't think it's a
match of Honor I think it's a failure of
A Sort I'm in a state of failure when I
have to work extremely diligently which
I do almost all the time so I'm
frequently failing and I hope to remedy
that so that I could start to relax and
spend some time with my wife which I do
get to I prioritize that luckily luckily
like hey the best parts of my life are
the fact that I I love my work and I
love my wife I dislike speaking about
what's immature or incipient immature as
in it's not developed yet so ideas even
this this is not something that's
terribly fun for me in fact it's
embarrassing I've watched day in the
lives of people and I feel like they're
manufactured and I thought hey man I
would love to see someone else's
disorgan organized and anarchistic day
that's what this is one option that I'm
toying with this so I don't know how
this is going to be edited and maybe
this is kept in maybe not one option is
to just leave it as that and this is a
day because this is a true day a true
day in the life it's not an average day
in the life of myself another option is
to come back and film once we've become
more settled another option is to go
into the boardroom and just point out
what is an average day for myself just
write it down I don't know but
this riotous day is an aberration
I better get going
and now is the wind down this cup this
is my cup my wife's cup peppermint
peppermint tea it doesn't have the
string I don't understand why people
have tea with the string and then you're
pouring the water and you have to
finagle the tea bag I like it simple
this is how I unwind usually my wife is
here but she's recording we watch some
comedy and then okay Google it's movie
time
and now I'm super excited super super
excited because a rare treat I I love
love potato chips love potato chips and
chocolate that's my weakness so I get to
eat this I eat it in a bowl with a spoon
because I'm strange and I don't like to
just touch it I don't want to get the
oil on my fingers and then onto the
remote control so that's it that's
pretty much the end of the day now I'm
gonna watch this show with my wife
and I appreciate you spending the day
with me
that was an unduly honest day in the
light and this is just a brief outro to
reference three topics number one I said
plexigam prior what plexdcam is is what
you're viewing this on I'll show a video
of before and after you'll see that my
face is considerably closer to the
camera as well as my eye line and I'm
not sponsored by plexigam I've reached
out to them saying I love your product
what can I do to help promote it they
said hey Kurt here's a link plexicam.com
so-and-so slash toe whatever it is I'm
gonna put it on the screen as well as
the description and so this way if you
want to try out the Plexi cam toe gets a
bit of a cut as well as you get a 10
discount and so it's win-win this is
great for any podcaster what else is
great for podcasters is stream yard in
fact I may be switching to them
completely over Zoom which is what I've
used for years stream yard is what I use
for the tonanza and again stream yard
has not sponsored me I've reached out to
them and said I love your product what
can I do then they said hey why don't I
just make you an affiliate link so this
way people get a discount and then you
get a bit of that as well again win-win
plexigam nor stream yard are sponsoring
me I just love their products and since
you've watched all the way to the end of
this day in the life for whatever reason
I thought maybe you'd be interested in
this thirdly the patreon now what you're
seeing is that we have this office we
were able to invest in this we were able
to get some people to work on Tow full
time that is there's an editor there's
an operations manager we want to get
more and more so that I'm less and less
stressed and able to put out higher
quality podcasts with higher quality
video with ever increasing depth with
ever increasing frequency and you help
that happen so if you would like to
continue to help that happen visit
patreon.com
that is
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l every bit
helps every dollar helps there's a
custom amount thank you so much there's
a Kurt plays the game everything coming
up and also just let us know in the
comments what else would you like to see
would you like to see more behind the
scenes of the pod podcast would you like
to see a month in the life or a year in
the Life Etc whatever your ideas are we
are constantly constantly innovating
with toe because of your support your
help thank you here's another fire this
morning I got a text from this office
place they say yeah Kurt you know how
you've been complaining about the
internet here can you be in here from
this from like 9am to this time because
they'll they're going and I said like
I'm sorry I'm just not available then
she's like okay well they're gonna come
they're gonna I'm like oh man because
it's not like anyone else here is
complaining about the internet as far as
I know so I want to explain to the I.T
people what specifically is going on why
is the upload speed so low we're trying
to sync so much footage we're trying to
download we're trying to upload I don't
like that at the end of the night it
says it's going to take five hours to
upload a one hour long video or six
hours up it should be happening in
minutes
so that's frustrating and then she's
like okay so Kurt they've come they
they're gonna do maintenance tomorrow
for an hour so the internet will be off
I'm like wait tomorrow when we have the
tonanza this live stream live stream
it's not even with the guest which
already is horrible because I'm
overzoomed with the guest it's a live
stream for eight hours where different
people Australia UK Canada the different
parts of the states they've all these
are huge names that have taken a few
minutes out of their hugely busy
schedule during the holidays to come and
say hi on the toenanza hey I know how
Bell I know how these companies work if
they say I'm coming at 2PM they may come
at nine they may come at 5 p.m I don't
know when they're coming if they say
it's only going to be off for an hour it
could be off for 10 minutes it could be
offered three hours it could be off for
the rest of the are you kidding me on
the and I'm like this is what I'm
dealing with but as soon as one hour
after I wake up on the hugest day for
tow in terms of livestream I've never
live streamed with audience like this
before little let alone have this many
guests so that's another issue that
we're dealing with the podcast is now
concluded did thank you for watching if
you haven't subscribed or clicked on
that like button now would be a great
time to do so as each subscribe and like
helps YouTube push this content to more
people also I recently found out that
external links count plenty toward the
algorithm which means that when you
share on Twitter on Facebook on Reddit
Etc it shows YouTube that people are
talking about this outside of YouTube
which in turn greatly AIDS the
Distribution on YouTube as well if you'd
like to support more conversations like
this then do consider visiting
theoriesofeverything.org again it's
support from the sponsors and you that
allow me to work on Tow full time you
get early access to ad-free audio
episodes there as well every dollar
helps far more than you may think either
way your viewership is generosity enough
thank you